[Music]
2022 could be a historic year for china
xi jinping is preparing to ask the
communist party congress for a third
term in office
what will this mean for the rest of the
world
and is conflict with america inevitable
[Music]
there's a lot to unpack around china and
it can be hard to really understand
what's going on so ed what does 2021
taught you about this man she and ping's
vision for china and indeed the
communist party's vision for china and
if they already the same the same thing
i see this year as uh xi jinping
preparing for the really major event
which is going to come sometime next
autumn
with a party congress when he breaks the
mould and becomes the first leader since
mao to have a third
term
and that and that could lead to a fourth
term and in order to do this he not only
has to exert his control over the
country but also set out an agenda a
reason a justification in fact for why
he needs to have this third five-year
term
and this is i think absolutely
fascinating because his agenda is a mix
of things that worry us
uh in in the west things like the
dominance of consumer tech the monopoly
power of the big tech companies the way
they use data
um inequality the sense that uh perhaps
you know our children spend too long
playing computer games and it's not very
good for them so a lot of a lot of these
concerns actually are shared between the
western china but he deals with them in
an incredibly authoritarian way and a
way that absolutely centralizes party
power so for instance clamping down on
the consumer tech companies destroying
perhaps we reckoned in october about
some like 2 trillion worth of value
you see the aggressive attitude towards
anyone who rocks the boat peng
schweither the tennis player and the
treatment of her so this is an
authoritarian way of dealing with a lot
of problems that the whole world faces
and i think it's in that kind of mix
it's a hugely complex and interesting
constellation of forces of
authoritarianism and taking on the big
problems of society
and i mean we will think and talk a lot
about what that means for the rest of
the world but what in practice does that
mean for people who live within china's
borders
well i think we need to remember
that
xi jinping and the communist party are
popular in china chinese nationalism and
pride within china is at an all-time
high
the chinese people feel that they're
doing very well in the world they look
at kovid for example and they see you
know the millions of deaths around the
world including in advanced democracies
and they think that their system strange
as it seems to also perhaps locking
everyone down as soon as a case arises
they see their extraordinary low death
rate as a mark of tremendous success
now of course uh there are people who
are unhappy about this china has a a bad
record for arresting journalists over a
million wiggers have been through these
re-education accounts in xinjiang so
this this is not nice for everybody by
any means but i don't i think we'd be
kidding ourselves in the west if we
thought that um the chinese people see
xi jinping and the ccp through the same
eyes as we do zany um did 2021 sort of
mark the the death of big private uh
enterprise in china what's going on what
do you make of that landscape
no i don't think it marked the death of
big private enterprise but it definitely
marked the very
serious clampdown and assertion of party
control and private business serves at
the sort of uh behest of and in further
to further the goals of the party
because it's just
extraordinary the scale of the domestic
shift in this year in this year before
the national park the communist party
congress that uh ed talked about the
assertion of sea's power the clampdown
on business as you say but also the
shift internationally and china is
determined as xi jinping says to you
know move to center stage globally it's
becoming more assertive internationally
even as it's becoming more authoritarian
and indeed autocratic at home there were
hopes that with you know the move from
trump to buy them there might be a
thawing of relations but that that
doesn't really seem to be um the case at
all a lot of people quickly jump to the
conclusion that this is a new cold war
is is the current u.s china relationship
indeed beginning a sort of new cold war
was that actually the wrong
lens through which to um look at
what might be happening with this sort
of neo-forming world order the original
cold war
had between the soviet union and the and
the west um was an ideological struggle
between two sort of parts of the world
that had remarkably little economically
to do with each other there was very
little trade um meaningful trade between
the two blocks what we have between the
us and china is something fundamentally
different this is the world's first
biggest and second biggest economy
incredibly interlinked modern
globalization is sort of built on those
linkages and there are lots and lots of
countries including the fastest growing
countries in asia that are hugely
integrated with the chinese economy
while also relying on the american
security guarantee and if you look at
the implications of that for biden
they're rather awkward because the more
he tries to galvanize support at home by
by kind of you know banging the drama
and calling this new cold war the hardy
he makes his job of building alliances
in southeast asia there are plenty of
countries there that look to the united
states for their security but look to
china for their prosperity and you if
you try and force them to choose america
might just find that they make the
choice for china rather than for the
united states taiwan comes up a lot um
as a question right so so what will
ultimately happen the status quo here is
full of tension and ambiguity and a
series of sort of threats that balance
each other out
and people are always jostling for
position between the taiwanese
government flirting with independence
but not too much try to show it does not
want to
join up with china as it at the moment
with xi jinping and the chinese
government for whom it is an absolute
national priority
to acquire taiwan and if we're thinking
over 20 or 30 years i think sort of they
will try and see that to a close but
over the next decade decade perhaps not
and then the united states where what's
staked there is it's its entire
strategic presence in the
pacific because the united states
does nothing to protect taiwan then all
its pr its promises to south korea and
japan are hugely undermined
so this is a this is the naughtiest of
of naughty problems and when i say
status quo i don't mean to suggest it's
going to be easy but i think the risks
for everybody including xi jinping of
moving right now are just too great
um so
i think it can be managed but but i
don't think it's comfortable for anybody
understanding what is going on in china
understanding what's happening where
it's going is is the single most
important job frankly that we have to do
and that you know it's nothing
nothing else is as dramatic i think in
its consequences for every other big
issue in the world so it's it's
enormously fascinating it's quite scary
um in many ways very difficult to make
sense of not least because it is you
know very very hard to get a sense of
what's going on in china but nothing
could be more important
hi this was part of a digital event
produced exclusively for subscribers to
the economist if you'd like to watch the
full discussion of this or of one of our
other events then click the link you'll
just have to register if you haven't
already or you can become an economist
subscriber to enjoy access to all of our
journalism thanks for watching